- Hey, what's up, everybody?
I'm back with Hallmark Christmas royalty,
Lacey Chabert, Candice Cameron Bure,
and Holly Robinson Peete, give it up.
(audience cheering)
♪ This is ladies day ♪
This is not night, but yeah.
(chuckles) Didn't think that through.
It's no secret that people
love Hallmark Christmas movies.
Some fans are so obsessed
they've watched all of them,
and there are over 130.
It's a lot of movies, just saying.
It made us wonder, is it possible to spot
a fake Hallmark Christmas movie title?
Just saying.
This is a game we're calling
Know your Hallmark Christmas movies?
Spot the fake and win a prize.
♪ Know your Hallmark Christmas movies ♪
♪ Spot a fake and you could win ♪
(Kelly laughing)
- [Lacey] Wow, it's impressive.
- Oh, my God.
Do y'all have wine when
you think of these?
Like, is there wine involved?
I love my team.
(bells ringing)
Jingle, jingle, girl.
First, we need a contestant.
Please welcome Jasmine
from Minneapolis, y'all.
- Hi, hi, everyone.
- You look adorable.
Say hi to Lacey, Candice, and Holly.
- Hey, Jasmine.
- Hey, Jasmine!
- Hi, Lacey. Hi, Candice. Hi, Holly.
- Hi, Jasmine.
- (laughs) Your voice got like
exponentially louder each time.
It was Holly!
- I am so thrilled.
- Oh, my God. No, I get it.
If my sister were here, she would be like,
first of all, asking y'all
for all the swag in the world.
But, Jasmine, exactly how big
of a Hallmark Christmas movie fan are you?
- I'm gonna make this clear.
I am the hugest fan there is.
I love all the Hallmark movies.
When COVID happened and
we were in quarantine,
I was so happy when they decided
to play the Christmas movies on
the weekends to give us some joy.
They just make you feel all good inside.
And I make my husband watch them.
I watch them with friends.
A girlfriend and I won a contest last year
where we watched a bunch of movies.
They just make me smile.
- I love that, nothing wrong with that.
Jasmine, are you ready to play the game?
- I am.
- All right, all right.
Here's how it works,
Holly, Candice, and Lacey
will each read a list
of three movies titles
and their descriptions.
One of those three will be fake.
Jasmine has to guess which one.
If she guesses correctly
two of three times,
she'll get a very cool holiday vacation.
And I'll try to help you out, Jasmine.
Does that sound good?
- Yes, thank you in advance, Kelly.
- I don't know if I'll be
help, but I'm gonna try.
All right, let's go,
Candice, you read first.
- Okay, The Santa Incident.
After his sleigh is shot down
while flying through military airspace,
Santa is sought for questioning
by Homeland Security.
Can Santa make them believe
in him before it's too late?
Movie two, The Night Before
The Night Before Christmas.
Santa crashes into the Fox family's house,
ends up with amnesia,
and loses his magic sack of presents.
The family must help Santa remember
who he is before Christmas is ruined.
Movie C, Oh No, Ho Ho, Santa Quit?
When the world stops believing in him,
Santa quits and heads to the beach
where he meets a girl whose Christmas wish
is to see her brother again.
Santa must choose between pina coladas
and if one person
believing in him is enough.
- Oh, my God.
If that last one is a real movie,
that will be what I'm watching tonight.
(all laughing)
- I'm gonna say I agree.
I'm going with C is not the real movie.
- Just to remind you,
there's a holiday vacation
on the line, Jasmine.
So, A, The Santa Incident.
B, The Night Before The
Night Before Christmas.
Or C, Oh No Ho Ho, Santa Quit?
(all laughing)
I hope it's that one.
- Oh No Ho Ho, Santa Quit?
(bell dings)
- Okay, but can we please make this movie?
'Cause it sounds awesome (laughs).
All right, wait. The
next one is from Holly.
Go ahead.
- Oh no, ho ho.
Okay, here we go.
So, okay, Jasmine, ready?
Movie A, It's Christmas, Carol.
Heartless publishing executive Carol
is visited by three
ghosts of her former boss.
Eve, Past Eve, Present
Eve and Future Eve, okay.
They had to Eve for each ghost
due to budget costs in the afterlife.
Okay, movie B, It's Christmas, Joy.
You know, like the name?
It's Christmas, comma Joy.
Joy is a dental hygienist who needs
a Christmas boyfriend
to impress her parents.
Desperate for a date,
Joy offers to drive Michael
home after his dental surgery.
But instead gives him extra Vicodin, okay.
And drives him to her parents' place.
And movie C, Jasmine, It's Christmas, Eve.
- Oh, with the eve, I gotcha.
- It's Christmas, Eve.
While stepping in as a
superintendent at her former school,
Eve is forced to cut the arts
program to balance the books.
But then, she falls for a music teacher
in fingerless gloves--
- Fingerless gloves?
- Who helps her rediscover
the power of Christmas.
Okay, Jasmine.
- And the power of rock
and roll with those gloves.
I gotta be honest. Okay, wait.
Which one is fake?
I don't really still know
if I know what A is about.
- I don't know.
The Vicodin doesn't sound very Hallmark-y.
So I'm gonna go with B,
It's Christmas, comma, Joy.
- Yeah, I'm gonna say if that's real too,
you need to think about the times.
(laughs) I don't think you
should be roofie-ing people
and taking them to your family.
- Opioid Christmas is not--
- Yeah, I don't think it's gonna--
But let's make it for fun, guys.
Is that the one? Is it B?
(bell dings)
Hey, you win!
(audience cheering)
We're actually sending you to
one of the top Hallmark
Christmas locations,
the charming mountain town
of Park City, Utah, which I love.
You will get four nights of modern
and luxurious accommodations
at Park City Peaks Hotel.
And dine at the popular
Versante Hearth and Bar.
It's gonna be awesome.
Are you excited?
- I am excited, yay!
- Oh, my God. Love you so much.